thomas bonsoir qu'elles vont donc été
les annonces ce soir de joe biden
et bien comme attendu pas de mesures de
restriction annoncées par le président
américain qui a surtout fait le point
sur la stratégie de la maison blanche
pour affronter cette période hivernale
et surtout faire face à l'émergence de
ce variant omicron qui est désormais
majoritaire sur le territoire américain
les états unis sont prêts voilà ce que
déclare joe biden la situation est très
différente par rapport au mois de mars
2020 et l'accent a surtout été mis par
le président américain sur les capacités
de test aux états unis qui vont être
grandement renforcé au cours des
prochains mois écoutez le président des
états unis il ya quelques instants
nous avons besoin de plus de tests oui
je tends mettons à disposition 20 milles
et willy nous visons une autoproduction
qui nous coûte 3 milliards de dollars
pour que chacun puisse s'en procurer en
mairie d'aramon
pharmacie oui nous avons mis en place
tous ces tests pcr que vous trouvez dans
les hôpitaux chez vos mails
joe biden a également annoncé le
déploiement de 1000 personnels
militaires pour venir en soutien aux
hôpitaux pour affronter donc l'émergence
de ce variant omicron sur le territoire
américain de nouveaux sites de
vaccination vont également être mises en
place évidemment la vaccination c'est ce
sur quoi insistent et grandement joe
biden lors de son allocution il a tenté
même de dépolitiser la question en
quelque sorte en soulignant le fait que
c'était la précédente administration
donc celle de donald trump qui avait
permis aux états unis d'être en
possession d'un grand nombre de vaccins
ils avaient également il a également
souligné le fait que donald trump a
déclaré il ya peu qu'il avait recouru à
la troisième injection il tente donc de
dépolitiser est de convaincre les
américains les plus récalcitrants il est
aussi revenu sur une mesure qu'il avait
mise en place l'obligation de
vaccination ou de test pour les employés
des entreprises de plus de 100 salariés
cette mesure avait d'abord été suspendu
et bien elle a été réintroduit dès la
semaine dernière par une cour d'appel
voilà donc pour les annonces de joe
biden qui a souhaité de bonnes fêtes aux
américains et qui a également expliqué
qu'il pourrait prochainement lever les
restrictions de voyage qui concerne les
pays d'afrique australe merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington pour
toutes ces précisions